para 2012 los alemanes emiten dos votos
en el día de elecciones la potencia
económica de europa es una democracia
parlamentaria y más de 60 millones de
personas están llamadas a votar
el canciller de este país no es
directamente elegido por sus votantes
sino por los diputados del bundestag el
parlamento federal alemán el primer voto
de los alemanes es para un candidato de
su circunscripción y el que obtenga la
mayoría de los votos se une
automáticamente al parlamento el segundo
voto es para el partido político y
determina el porcentaje general que cada
partido recibe en el parlamento para
entrar al parlamento un partido debe
contar con al menos el 5% de los votos
acostumbrados a las coaliciones los
alemanes dividen su voto con frecuencia
entre dos partidos diferentes el número
de legisladores varía según las
papeletas y algunos cálculos complejos
debe haber al menos quinientos noventa y
ocho pero la actual legislatura tiene
709 de acuerdo a las proyecciones
electorales podría haber hasta 750
diputados en el nuevo gobierno y los
alemanes votan a 4 años